why why would Hollywood producers want
women to think the hard-working man
who's loyal to them is bad for trying to
stop weird strangers from sleeping with
her why would Hollywood producers want
women to have that in their head keep
saying Hollywood but it's Hallmark
Hollywood Hallmark all of it made in
Canada Hallmark is like way over the
line but all of these Hollywood movies
follow similar tropes like the man who
meets all of society's standards for
what a responsible man is isn't good
enough we either depict him as being
like you know bad in some emotional way
you know there's there's always a catch
the good hard-working man always has
problems and like The Lovable loser
always has a heart of gold and genuinely
cares for you it's like sorry no